where we left off in the last video we
saw a muhammad being born into a tribal
arabia he's born into a powerful tribe
the Quraish who are in control of Mecca
but his early life is difficult his
mother dies when he's six his
grandfather who's taken charge of him
dies when he's eight years old but he's
able to under the care of his uncle
become a merchant and at the age of
twenty five
he marries a wealthy merchant widower
named cathedra who was fifteen years his
senior then we saw at age forty in 610
while meditating in a mountain outside
of Mecca he receives the first
revelation of the Quran according to
Islamic tradition and he's skeptical of
it at first but he is reassured and then
he soon receives many more revelations
and within roughly three years he starts
to preach those revelations now as we
mentioned in that last video what he was
preaching did not sit well with his own
tribe those who ruled Mecca the Quraish
he was preaching a monotheistic
tradition based on Judaism and
Christianity he was pretty was preaching
that there is no god but God
but Mecca power its economy was based on
people making pilgrimages there to
worship the idols at the Kaaba so the
creation did not like Muhammad's
revelations and they did not like these
early Muslims and they persecuted them
they killed them they tortured them and
we saw in 615 the migration of some of
Muhammad's followers to Abyssinia the
kingdom of Aksum modern-day Eritrea and
Ethiopia to escape some of that
persecution things got worse for
Muhammad we saw in that last video the
death of his first wife and up to that
point his only wife and this is where we
start to see a bit of a turning point
for Muhammad and his followers in six
20 and this is according to Muslim
traditions there isn't historical
evidence for this and this is one of the
more metaphysical events that we'll talk
about in this narrative but according to
the Islamic faith in 620 Mohammed had a
night journey from Mecca to the farthest
mosque which today is believed by many
Muslims to be the al-aqsa mosque which
was built later in Jerusalem so right
right let me write over here so a night
journey according to the Muslim faith to
Jerusalem where he ascended with Gabriel
to the heavens and he had any conversed
with some of the prophets of old and
once again this is clearly a
metaphysical thing but it's a
significant of event in the Muslim faith
now the Quraish continued to persecute
Muhammad and the early Muslims in Mecca
we have some of them that are now in the
kingdom of Aksum and Muhammad learns
that there is a community a growing
community of Muslims in the town of
Yathrib who are starting to follow
Muhammad or his revelation and they come
to him and they invite him to come to
Yathrib because there's actually a lot
of fragmentation there's a there's
warring tribes and they're seeking an
outsider to help bring some peace and
authority to this place where there is
already a burgeoning Muslim community so
in 622 you have the famous migration of
Muhammad and his followers to Yathrib
which is renamed Medina and Medina
literally means the city and from then
on it really becomes the base of
Muhammad and the early Muslims and
Muhammad did this once he's in Medina he
is no longer just a prophet he isn't
just continuing to have his revelations
according to Islamic tradition but he
essentially rules over Medina and
governs it
he's starting to become both a political
ruler and a spiritual ruler now the
Quraish in Mecca are still not happy
because Muhammad is continuing to preach
and he's continuing to get more and more
followers and so you start having us at
first a series of skirmishes between the
armies or of the Quraish or the members
of the creation and some of the early
Muslims but these skirmishes eventually
emerge into full-on conflict and here
are some of the significant battles that
occurred between
the Quraish tribe remember that's
Muhammad's own tribe and the early
Muslims the early followers of Muhammad
and his revelations so most famously
perhaps you have the Battle of Badr
because this is the first time that you
have a significant confrontation between
a very small that you wouldn't even
necessarily call this an army a small
group of Muslims roughly a little over
300 according to Muslim tradition versus
900 or a little over 900 on the Quraish
side and the Muslims are outnumbered
three to one
but this results in a Muslim victory and
so you can imagine the early Muslims
start to see this is a turning tide they
were able to defeat the powerful Quraish
tribe now the Quraish works happy with
that and roughly a year later you have
another battle outside of Medina on
Mount on Mount Hood and once again the
Muslims which are now larger but they
continued to be outnumbered even more
than 3 to 1 this is closer to 4 to 1
right over here and this results in a
Quraish victory this is right over there
outside on the northern side of what is
now called Medina but then a few years
later you have a significant battle
where the Quraish are have built a
confederacy and they want to end this
this the teachings of Muhammad they want
to end these Muslims who are threatening
whose preachings are threatening the
pilgrimage the legitimacy of the Quraysh
tribe in Mecca
and so they laid siege to the city of
Medina and as a defensive measure the
Muslims in Medina create a trench around
the city and that's why this is called a
the Battle of the trench and once again
according to Islamic tradition the
Muslims are outnumbered three to one so
this is right over here the battle
battle of the trench in which the
Muslims are victorious and this is a
significant blow to the legitimacy the
prestige of the Quraysh tribe a year
later you have the treaty of hudaibiya
between the Quraish and the Muslims and
this is significant because it's
starting to put these early Muslims on
the same footing as the powerful Quraish
tribe it has some allowances for the
Muslims to make pilgrimages to the Kaaba
but then as we go into 630 there's an
incident in which one tribe is it kills
some members of another tribe remember
we're still in a very tribal society and
the other tribe the one that had some
members killed was aligned was friendly
with the early Muslims so the early
Muslims did not appreciate this they
sent an ultimatum to the Quraish and the
creation essentially say well you know
that doesn't matter we don't really take
what you have to say seriously and they
take one of the options of the ultimatum
which is making the treaty of hudaibiya
null and void so now that the treaty is
not there and once again this is
according to Muslim traditions which are
our main accounts that we have of this
time we then have in 630 10,000 Muslims
which is a very significant number
remember we're six years ago we're
talking about only 300 Muslims in the
Battle of Badr but ten thousand Muslims
march on Mecca and they are able to take
the city peacefully and what this
results in is essentially most of the
city converting to Islam and famously
Muhammad goes into the Kaaba and
destroys the idols there
and according to Islamic tradition makes
the Kaaba a center of the Muslim faith
and it is even today now from that point
the the spread of Islam continues you
have Muhammad and his armies this green
areas essentially what they were able to
conquer in the remainder of his life and
he lives for another he lives whoops
he lives for another two years after the
acceptance of Islam by Mecca and they're
able to conquer most of this green this
dark green area here and as we'll see
shortly after that most of Arabia and
even Persia and within a few hundred
years a large chunk of the world were
able to be conquered by these Muslim
armies